DOG CAST IF ICE CREAM.
RAYMOND ARROYO HAS IT ALL.
FIRST, USING AND ABUSING THE
TRUST.
THAT’S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT’S
"ANGLE."
IT SEEMS LIKE ONLY YESTERDAY
WHEN THE DEMOCRATS WERE WORRIED
ABOUT DEPLOYING THE MILITARY
AGAINST ANTIFA AND THE BLM MOB
WHO WERE RAMPAGING ACROSS OUR
CITIES LAST SUMMER.
>> MISUSE OF OUR AMERICAN
MILITARY FOR HIS POLITICAL
CAMPAIGN.
UNABLE TO UNITE US.
>> HE IS MISUSING MILITARY.
IT’S NOT THE ROLE THE U.S.
MILITARY TO GO INTO CITIES AND
STATES AND UNDERMINE LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS DEGRADED
THE INDEPENDENCE OF THE MILITARY
AND IGNORED SOME OF THE
DANGEROUS TENDENCIES OF
POLITICAL ACTIVITY WITHIN THE
MILITARY.
>> Laura: THOSE DEMOCRATS HAVE
HAD A CHANGE OF HEART.
THE LIBERAL D.C. MAYOR ANNOUNCED
THAT 5,000 NATIONAL GUARD WILL
REMAIN IN D.C. THROUGH MARCH.
THIS IS DOWN FROM THE NUMBER OF
25,000 WHO WERE CALLED UP AFTER
THE JANUARY 6TH CAPITOL RIOT.
DID THEY THINK THAT INSANE
ANIMAL SKIN GUY WAS RETURNING TO
D.C.?
I DON’T THINK SO.
THIS IS POLITICAL THEATER
DIRECTED BY DEMOCRAT LEADERSHIP.
THEY ARE USING THE MILITARY TO
RATCHET UP THE DRAMA OF THEIR
KANGAROO IMPEACHMENT TRIAL OF
FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP.
IT ALLOWS THEM TO PLAY THE
VICTIM DESPITE EVIDENCE OF ANY
SERIOUS ON-GOING THREAT.
IT FURNISHES THEM WITH A BACK
DOORWAY TO PURGE THE MILITARY OF
ANY POLITICAL OPPONENTS.
ACCORDING TO THE HILL, DEMOCRATS
WILL ACCOMPLISH THIS BY
INSERTING LANGUAGE INTO THIS
YEAR’S NATIONAL DEFENSE
AUTHORIZATION ACT TO ADDRESS
EXTREMISM AT THE PENTAGON AND
OTHER FEDERAL AGENCIES.
WE KNOW SOME GROUPS HAVE TO
RECOUNT PERSONNEL INTO THEIR
CAUSE OR ENCOURAGE MEMBERS TO
JOIN THE MILITARY FOR SKILLS AND
EXPERIENCE.
OF COURSE, THIS IS ALL KIND OF
VAGUE FOR A REASON.
THE BROADER AND MORE OPAQUE THE
LANGUAGE, THE EASIER IT IS TO
CANCEL MILITARY MEMBER AND
OTHERS WHO DON’T CALL IN LINE
POLITICALLY OR EVEN CULTURALLY.
MOST PEOPLE WOULD AGREE THAT
GENERALLY DANGEROUS EXTREMISTS
SHOULD NOT BE ALLOWED TO SERVE
AND JOIN THE MILITARY.
WE WON’T MEMBERS OF ISIS IN OUR
RANKS AND OBVIOUSLY KKK, OF
COURSE NOT.
THAT’S NOT WHO THE DEMOCRATS ARE
TALKING ABOUT.
>> WHEN WHITE EXTREMIST GROUPS
WE ARE UNABLE TO ADDRESS THOSE
GROUPS.
>> THE FEAR THAT OTHER
AMERICANS, PRESIDENT TRUMP’S
SUPPORTERS WILL HARM THEIR
FELLOW AMERICANS.
SOME FAR RIGHT EXTREMISTS.
>> WHAT IS THE DEFINITION OF THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY OR ARE THERE
SEVERAL?
>> THERE ARE SEVERAL BUT THE
LARGEST ARE TRUMP LOYALTIES AND
PART OF THAT FACTION IS
CONSPIRACY KOOKS.
>> Laura: THEY WANT TO FEEL THE
NARRATIVE NOT ONLY IS YOUR
CONSERVATIVE NEIGHBOR OR FAMILY
MEMBER SUPICIOUS, BUT THE
MILITARY IS FULL OF RIGHT WING
EXTREMISTS READY TO RISE UP.
>> TO RID OUR RACE OF RACISTS
AND EXTREMISTS AND CREATE
A CLIMATE WHERE EVERYONE FIT AND
WILLING HAS THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SERVE THIS COUNTRY WITH DIGNY.
-- DIGNITY.
WE CAN’T KEEP US  SAFE --
>> Laura: HE SAID WE CAN’T
PROVIDE FOR THE NATIONAL DEFENSE
UNLESS IS PURGES UNDESIRABLES
WITHIN THE MILITARY RANKS.
FORGET THE FACT THAT CHINA IS
POISED FOR GLOBAL DOMINATION.
>> THE RISE OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
EXTREMISM IS A NATIONAL SECURITY
THREAT.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION WILL
CONFRONT THIS THREAT.
THE FIRST IS A TASKING FROM
PRESIDENT BIDEN REQUESTING
A THREAT ASSESSMENT TO DRAW ON
THE ANALYSIS FROM ACROSS THE
GOVERNMENT.
>> Laura: WHOA, WHOA, WHOA.
WHAT NON-GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATIONS IS SHE TALKING
ABOUT THAT WILL REPORT ON THEIR
FELLOW AMERICANS?
THE ACLU, BLACK LIVES MATTER,
PLANNED PARENTHOOD.
>> ANTI-GUN RIGHTS
ORGANIZATIONS?
THEY THINK ANYONE WHO DISAGREES
WITH THEIR FAR LEFT GOALS ARE
EXTREMISTS.
FROM WHAT WE HAVE ALREADY HERD
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION SAY,
IT’S CHLOR THAT THEY ARE GOING
TO USE THE POWER AND
SURVEILLANCE OF THE U.S.
GOVERNMENT TO KEEP TABS ON A LOT
MORE PEOPLE THAN WE EVER WOULD
HAVE THOUGHT WOULD HAVE BEEN
EMBEDDED IN GOVERNMENT AGENCIES
AS DOMESTIC TERRORISTS.
YES, LAW-ABIDING AMERICANS WHOM
THE PARTY IN POWER THINKS THEY
ARE GETTING OUT OF THE LINE.
>> THEY WILL UNDERTAKE A POLICY
REVIEW EFFORT TO DETERMINE HOW
THE GOVERNMENT CAN SHARE
INFORMATION ABOUT THIS THREAT.
SUPPORT EFFORTS TO SUPPORT
RADICALIZATION.
>> Laura: SOME ARE SUPPORTING
A BROADER PURGE.
STEPHANIE MURPHY PROPOSED A BILL
TO KEEP TRUMP SUPPORTERS FROM
GETTING SECURITY CLEARANCES.
SHE ASKED ABOUT THEIR ROLE IN
ACTIVITIES.
ATTENDANCE AT AN EVENT TO
DELEGITIMIZE THE RESULTS OF
A PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION RAISES
SERIOUS QUESTIONS ABOUT AN
APPLICANT’S SUITABLE FOR
A SECURITY CLEARANCE.
WOW.
PRESIDENT PIN WOULD BE PROUD.
DRIVE OUT ALL POLITICAL
OPPOSITION.
FORCE EVERY DAY AMERICANS TO
LIVE IN FEAR.
ENCOURAGE NEIGHBORS TO SNITCH ON
NEIGHBORS AND FAMILIES AGAIN
FAMILIES AND AMERICAN AGAINST
AMERICAN.
THE MESSAGE IS CLEAR.
IF YOU ARE A CONSERVATIVE WHO
HAS ANY QUESTIONS ABOUT ELECTION
IRREGULARITIES, YOU BETTER SHUT
UP IF YOU WANT TO KEEP YOUR JOB.
FIRST AMENDMENT?
FOR GET IT ABOUT IT.
IT’S IRONIC IT’S CHEERED ON BY
THE MEDIA.
-->> IT WILL TAKE A WHILE TO
REMOVE THOSE ELEMENT FROM
POSITION OF AUTHORITIES.
>> THIS SCREENING NEEDS TO
HAPPEN ACROSS THE ENTIRE
MILITARY AND WE SHOULD BE
REMOVING PEOPLE THAT ARE MEMBERS
EVEN IF THEY ARE NOT ACTIVE
MEMBERS.
>> YOU CAN’T STAND BY AND SEE
PEOPLE IN UNIFORM LAW
ENFORCEMENT OR MILITARY HAVE
QANON PATCHES ON.
>> Laura: THIS IS POISONOUS FOR
THE COUNTRY.
REPUBLICANS HAVE TO STAND UP AND
STOP DEMOCRATS FROM TARGETING
OUR ACTIVE DUTY MILITARY
PERSONNEL OR OUR VETS.
THESE MEN AND WOMEN HAVE ENDURED
REPEATED
REPEATED TOURS OF DUTY AND
RISKING LIFE AND LIMB AND NOW
THEY ARE TARGETED BY ELECTION
OFFICIALS IN AT HOME.
REPUBLICANS NEED TO DEMAND THAT
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION CLEARLY
DEFINE WHAT THEY THINK
CONSTITUTES EXTREMISM.
IF A MEMBER OF THE MILITARY
VOTED FOR TRUMP DOES THAT MAKE
HIM AN EXTREMIST?
WHAT IF SOMEONE COMPLAINS ON
FACEBOOK THAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT WASTES ONEMONEY OR SA
ROE V. WADE SHOULD BE
OVERTURNED.
OR WHAT IF THEY ARE CONSERVATIVE
BAPTISTS AND BELIEVE SEX OUTSIDE
OF MARRIAGE IS IMMORAL?
WILL THEY NOW BE CONSIDERED
EXTREMISTS OR EVEN TERRORISTS?
WE DESERVE TO KNOW.
YOU SEE WHERE THIS IS DESTINED
TO LEAD.
IT IS NOT TO A FREER AND MORE